hi everyone it's Jerry I am going to
play an hourly super Blitz Arena
57 minutes
of 3-0
all right
matanzas
okay we have played lots of games
all right let's go with C6 here
oh actually
recalling a game we had
I think it was this opponent
now I could be mistaken
okay
let's see
they have space
yeah I was thinking of a game
that I lost
with a Catalan opening but this is no
Catalan and I didn't lose my last game
against this guy
Okay so
I flicked this A5 move in because I
don't want to see a quick B4
P4
B4 B5
and they're going for that
I'm actually thinking I should have
maybe
played this instead of Bishop here
try and get this Exchange in
and then clamp down on the B4 idea but
the timing is not there I was
threatening a trick there if they pushed
Knight takes Pawn was available
in fact it's still there if they play in
that way
um it seems healthy going here
okay so they're getting out of that
trick
wondering if I should try this I'm gonna
go for it
I'm gonna get a weak Pawn one way or the
other
to watch over this guy
and now this guy so I guess it turned
out rookie 8 is
pretty much a waste
and now they have a nice grip there
yeah I'm really not liking my decision
there to play
H6 this is going to be
a problem isn't it
I do have a square here this is my only
Square
Queen is close to out of squares oh I
missed
well actually they missed something here
I didn't see that that was hanging
and they didn't see that their Knight
was hanging
okay
uh let's go for this one I guess or I
guess I could exchange
I do have the Knight supporting this way
down on the clock
I don't think my queen is getting
trapped and with this tension between
the Rooks no Rook C2
okay and now they're Queen what if I
threaten mate
can have a Perpetual no they don't have
a perpetual
okay back they go
I guess let's start here
sort of seems like an improvement
a queen exchange do not mind that
being up the piece
dropping a lot of stuff
let's try and get this guy off
all right what's the cleanest way to
approach this bring my king over
stop King there
for a second
you want to round up this poem
very shaky start here
now two on this no Pawn push here
in fact Let me let me just come up like
this
my king could scoop them up
not sure exactly where I'm going
to watch out for Forks
all the time
okay
oh well they're dropping a lot of stuff
yeah that's too much
just have to watch out for stalemites
tricky pawn moves
I really lucked out with this one this
is a Bad start
I'll be able to bring home the point
here
or will I
oh
stalemate just as I was saying that
I got too confident there I'll be able
to bring home the full point I say
ah man
such an elementary mistake
okay I got that bad start out of my
system I guess I hope I hope I got it
out of my system
I should just threw that Bishop in the
corner I normally do that
if you have too much material just
demote the pieces so that they have no
Mobility
ah unfortunately that Bishop was a
contributor taking away a key
Square from the King
all right that's a long game
a close to nine minute game one and I
got one point
okay
that was messy for both of us really
hmm maybe I can hop around
that E6 Square
it's looking appealing
I was expecting them to capture and then
play Knight to F6
I'm ducking the Knight exchange because
I don't want this guy to see the world
so easily
I guess
I don't know I can't can I still work my
way into this Square
I guess I could
feels a little weird doing it like this
but I know you know what I could play
here first I was thinking that my knight
could be kicked but I have pressure here
so this is this is far more harmonious
running it like this
it's not going to be hitting with check
but that would be a huge weakness
to play H6 with these two here
and all right now
now it can't be played because I it's no
longer a check but it's
might as well be check
okay
Simba is my opponent
Simba 2002 first time playing
don't know from where
all right
I'm tempted to just jump right in here
I'm wondering a bit though about
exchange sacrifices
Maybe
uh
maybe I could push this guy around I was
thinking about B3 as well
okay
night's not
doing so good here I guess
I guess I could jump in uh
it's an exchange sacrifice here I got
the F4 Square covered I don't think they
have enough
if they go for that this Knight doesn't
really have anything
I could glue The Rook in there I think I
like that idea
now there's no exchange sacrifice with
the queen is the leader for the battery
pretty stable Rook this guy's not gonna
bother The Rook
this is the only one that could bug The
Rook
I guess I could have even considered
Knight G5 I could revisit this
and why not in fact
I got a lot of stuff Happening Here
don't he
so there's there should be a good move
for me Knight takes h7s looking
appealing
I got these squares covered Bishops have
them Colleen has this that's the
important one
I'm surprised they didn't play this yet
is there some other move
but they think about Queen takes and
then maybe bishop here
possibly
and I'm gonna go for this one
and no light Square bishop and I have an
unopposed light Square Bishop
tactics should be there
or they're more likely to be there
unopposed light Square Bishop
a lot of stuff here okay so my first
thought was just chop that night
I don't have to though I could take the
material
and circle back if Knight takes Rook
now I'm gonna hold off from saying this
should be a
smooth conversion
you'll learn my lesson
we'll see
let's give the queen a kick no rush in
taking this guy
still doesn't have a square
Queen is almost trapped
out here
like to take here with Tempo if possible
I'd prefer not to move my F Pawn
okay let's take the pun with the tempo
and Bishop is pinned I have good
coordination
uh
um I guess let's get this guy in the
ball game
plenty of time in the tank
that night has a square now
not the not the greatest square but
I want to open up my Rook size
Queen's defending the Rook
up and over
Queen takes I have this
where's the me
one
two okay
all right
some lengthy games there
first two is in first
Dragon Sword ooh
running with some all-out berserk
sm-46 okay
let's try G6
um
try this one
we'll go with the double theme kiddo
and grab some space uh
go and let's just continue to develop
and I thought there might be some
pressure on that guy soon
I'm there to recapture
all right my knight is pinned how
concerning is that
uh
let's just take
oh
okay let me cancel before there's maybe
this
okay
how about oh wait a second though
if I play Knight here this bishop is
having a tough time
yeah
I'm tracking this guy down soon I
believe unless there's some night move
here because my Bishop is unprotected
okay
so I could take this guy
but I could also
still
not take it
it's like my Knights pinning the bishop
in this case
all right I'll take them now that he's
ready to run away
and let's complete development Bishop's
now defended there shouldn't be any
wonderful tactics about this one as a
start
that seems good too
how can I get my dark Square Bishop
working
is it worthwhile to flick this
worthwhile to flick that one in I think
it is don't let you don't let this guy
begin to improve
um maybe here
I don't mind the queen exchange or even
The Rook exchange I think
I think in the end
I wonder about Rook A4 how's that
playing out is my a pawn just gonna fall
I wonder
okay I guess I'll go there
maybe just just play it where I
centralize the king back to
Back to Basics
I'm not sure exactly where I'm going
though honestly
what should my plan be
okay this night is kind of stuck I don't
know let's
going over here
if I move my knight there's going to be
that push Maybe
this Square opened up
still gonna get that pushing
okay I guess I could take I don't mind
that I feel like this guy was a
liability
if I attacked am I gonna be able to
defend him easily
let's go somewhere else maybe I should
have played here
can't push here I could take away and
then in the end land a fork
I might have this on the cards okay
oh there
they missed that I'm on that pawn that's
a huge Pawn
huge
also there's a huge clock Advantage for
white
so my knight is stable I have all the
important pawns covered maybe I could
try to drive this guy up here okay
maybe improve my king
actually I wonder why did I why'd I take
that Bishop off that diagonal
so easy to miss a fork I can't push this
Pawn
okay I don't mind that
oh I could have made things so simple
King and pawn ending could have got the
Knight there if the night moves I get I
gain some ground
are they in a pickle here
I'm not exactly
I guess they have to play King there
they're not doing that so
their Knight is under control I should
be winning the second Pawn
the good coordination with my bishop and
structure
okay I have that pawn
keep the night offset
just shuffling
making back to a
a decent Square
there that's the one I should have
played earlier
bringing it to a King and pawn ending
okay this time no stalemates
little stalemates
that
is not stalemate
plenty of time
okay
long games man
I don't think I'm gonna do any
berserking
just trying to play some
decent games
just shy of 300 in here
cause
I'll try you for
ah I get a little wild
it's as Wild As It Gets with me H4
that'll scare them
all right
I don't mind
I know it's a my good Bishop for their
bad Bishop however I wonder about let's
try something
a bit different just to mess with their
structure
I don't want to allow that that would be
a rock solid structure there
so we'll see
positional Pawn sacrifice
this guy here
I may even be okay giving up a second
upon
they might go after one of these two
I might might get there okay this seems
interesting Knight B5 or maybe Knight C2
reinforcing D4
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna Castle
kingside I don't like going in that
direction but
I really don't have many options wait a
second what if I take here and take here
get the pawn back I think I'm good with
that
I still have control over this Square
maybe maybe they back off and they get
this going
maybe I jump in though let's try this
oh I'm on this Pawn as well oh they
might miss that
they're thinking
they might miss it
and now they didn't miss it okay and
then they the Nike block
if I took there right away okay
uh you know what I don't know if I want
to Castle I think I'm gonna get my
King out of here though
that Bishop has stopping castling over
here maybe I go Queen side uh
okay I
yeah I guess I go here
go after this Pawn
be very very careful okay oh yeah
oh okay
this is going to be a problem
okay I guess this is my way
to defend the pawn
it's not fun
I could have played B4 but I guess I'm
caring a bit more about
about what exactly
a bit more about improving my night
I have this move
that's why I went here to keep pressure
on F5 I don't want to see this
get going okay
they have a push but I have this Rook
wait a second
I could take here there's no Bishop
check
let's get off of this diagonal
now their Bishop is pinned
I have this covered would I take it
they'd be unpinned if I take it maybe I
wouldn't want to take it okay
where do I put my Rook
probably here just stay super
coordinated this could fall with check
I could also flick this in with check
it's still a pin along the G file
the watch out for Bishop here and queen
here that would be mate
okay let's start with that one
defend here
I could take even if there's a push now
I think I'm ready to go with this one
could take with check they probably
should have played here
maybe still losing if they go there but
now it's much easier to calculate any
bishop move its check aside from Bishop
f8
okay I didn't see that one I think I
could scare them away now
uh is there a cleaner approach
uh what about this actually
it's targeting this I was thinking about
the checks
and then here and then and then a check
here
it's probably winning but I think this
might be
easier to calculate I just want to
pinpoint this guy
okay and
the checks
I could take here
Omega one
Bishop here I could take
I could take with the queen there's no
accident happening on G2
no Perpetual no stalemate ideas
I got Pawns
I guess that's the only try
yeah
it might go for Rook takes I guess they
have to try that
okay let's just go here on that
okay we got this one
okay that was sloppy
that's what I get for H4
okay
man time flies
33 minutes
I got nine I got fire that was my first
four
my first round opponent is cruising 24.
okay let's see what opening we could
play here
first of all
what's white throwing at us D4
okay how about
well maybe we try a xinji Indian
opponents playing like I did
the last game all right
I want to meet H5 with G5
that's all I'm saying with H6
this square is a bit weakened
so
pins could be irritating all right now
now I think I want to challenge with
this guy I don't have to worry about
going uncastled with this guy in the way
okay this is
this is a welcome site
I don't mind the bishop check I still
don't mind being being on castled here
um it's not forced
being uncastled
uh let's start with
yeah I think that Bishop's gonna be
pretty good no matter what oh fancy
okay
okay are they I mean are they really
going for oh no Queen here I'm covering
I'm thinking something like this and
here queen queen here straight away with
some double attack forgetting my knight
is covering it from F6
all right what's the story with this guy
I want to wait for Knight F6 before I go
here
uh is this okay or
I guess I'll go here
something like this in here I don't know
if it's really a big deal I could always
play this one that's what they're going
for I don't mind weakening my light
squares so much
I'm covering it
my Bishop's watching over C6 that's the
main
weakness maybe I could even
soften up a square or two
okay actually I was waiting for a move
like this
um Knight G4
is extra appealing going after
this is the this is the good guy going
after the good Bishop so
and similar to that that earlier game
I'm in this position where I see the
Knight is I should be a bit patient
there with the capture
or maybe not actually because Knight
here and then if I'm capturing the
Knight gets to recapture an eye up that
square
so I wonder if I should flick that in
now although this guy might be extra
hungry
all right I have two paths into this
super weak Square I think now I want to
take before they have that maneuver
okay and now
I think I'm cool with castles
I guess The Bishop's gonna go here no
matter what
swatching over
my knight getting to this Square
this move I'm playing here there's no
sacrifices that's a scan I did before
castling
I do not want the H file to be peeled
open I don't want a knight for two pawns
being exchanged they would only get one
with my queen around here this guy is in
a pin this guy is unprotected
this guy could do something better
maybe I should have considered this move
okay they're castling
okay
so
I'm kind of drawn to this one actually
yeah because if the Knight moves I could
take the pawn now and I'm also stopping
H5 altogether okay that's weakening
though
um
okay I'm gonna go here knowing that I
could get pinned my Rook will be out of
place
out of play
okay they didn't go for that I should
probably look to exchange my knight if
they go here I should duck The Exchange
okay get to the open file
oh I'm just realizing hmm okay my Bishop
could be in a little bit of trouble
after G4 but I'd still have Queen takes
H4
maybe I just go all the way back or
no this is my favorite piece so far I
think they should challenge it
okay now that now that isn't a move
I'm gonna try this
giving this square up but I have a plan
of here here
uh I have to be careful night there
is hitting my Bishop
okay let's do this first
this and then this oh
I want Bishop H6
yes
just staring at my own pawns here
okay I'm on the queen don't have to move
the bishop just yet
I could take the Rook as well
and why why not
yeah I'm gonna take that
just come all the way back
okay
that Bishop is really good
these pawns control the night okay
there's a check
that Bishop is really good
maybe I should be playing a five or
willing to give up some material to open
some lines I gotta go faster
much faster
watch that doesn't fall
now after a queen Exchange
stay focused
not sure what I'm doing exactly with
that
check I'm not afraid of okay they were
spending a lot of time there
that was messy
um you know what
if I might
my first thought here is I should have
went for the material
Bishop takes Rook
don't like that decision
it felt it felt like an environment
there that was more suitable for minor
pieces
still very locked my Rooks were really
clumsy there at the end
what was the their productive role
I don't know
okay
one chess player more
quick pressure here
in my Center
all right I'll keep it
still keep the tension
I was gonna say that I'm okay with being
on castled I think I think that's
correct but I I'm not forced
to to play in that way I could take once
and then if they're capturing
take once and then do something like
that
is it worthwhile to play here I don't
think so
I think those two ponds are pretty good
if I'm going to take I'm going to take
this guy because there's fewer options
on the recapture
there's three
three ways black can be recapturing I
think it's best to take with the pawn
but
that's my reasoning with that decision
okay
that's got to be a good move
open file
I'm just gonna go here I know hmm
now let's not do that I'm afraid of
Knight exchange Rook exchange Bishop D6
and F4
okay
some light Square weaknesses now
Maybe
maybe this actually I wonder if I should
be playing with my F Pawn there's a big
difference here actually on the e-file
E5 is a whole E4 is not a whole
well maybe I don't have to
play F4 now if I could why would I want
to play F4 it's to stop black from
playing F4 but if I currently it seems
like I'm cool with
piece play
um
let's go here some restriction
way down on the clock
I'm restricting the Knight it's my big
idea there
all right let's go for this now
there's going to be some pressure on
okay
it's gonna be some pressure on
D5
the bishop takes Knight takes
okay
uh take I guess take
that Bishop here is going to be played
isn't it
okay it's getting
chaotic here
takes F5 okay maybe I should
I was also on that a lot no let's play
in the center actually instead of f4 the
more committal if I'm kicked and I now
have this Square uh we're these are now
both holes okay they're cutting that one
out
let's try and stop this idea
if this I can take once and play here
uh I guess here
am I prepared really to give up my light
Square Bishop for the night I may be
I think I should be able to maintain my
knight okay
didn't see that one
oh they they're not controlling this
anymore
take their my time though
okay I think I want to play this
yeah
can't allow a light Square Bishop
exchange and then that night to
jump in there
and go after this guy I guess queen of
two I could unpin
shouldn't be any problem if they form a
battery with the queen Knight C2
okay Queens the one putting pressure
here Knight here King H2
prefer not to play this
um
let's just try to blunder
okay let's go here
time
I don't mind the doubled Pawns
I'm on this this point maybe I should
have played that
Queen E5 next
okay I don't see how their Queen gets
active
my time
now I'm seeing how their Queen can get
active
clean check gets the Queens off
I'm gonna go for that try and make life
simpler
they're not taking my oh they missed the
queen
whoops
yeah I was wondering
they're taking some time there why am I
going on a light Square
foreign
totally unnecessary they're having some
serious connection issues
they keep blinking
let's not stalemate
okay
20 minutes to go
Where Do We Stand oh just barely page
one
this guy
first round opponent is cruising
pretty good berserk right there 90
percent
okay
it's still possible to get top three not
catching him
okay David uh
go e45
okay C3 you say all right I don't have
to worry about Knight C3
so that's why I feel a bit more
comfortable bringing my queen out early
okay early coin exchange
I don't think he could really take
advantage of the king
so let's just continue to develop
okay
let me flick this in I don't want to see
this guy
get going anytime soon so
Center Fork tricks
I don't know that they're
gonna be there these seem like all
healthy moves what I'm doing here
I don't think I'm doing anything wrong
um how about
you know they've they've cut out any
Bishop G4 so
[Music]
okay that seems healthy as well
um
keep developing
uh this this move has been crossing my
mind
for many moves now
I feel like it could get hit with the
pawn advance
this is unprotected okay you're not
moved I'm gonna I'm gonna move too
we're back to fighting for similar
squares
wow that is that is a
super weakening move
am I not ready though right now
to chop here
should be able to enter
you have to take with the Knight
otherwise I win the night
okay
okay let's take
and I guess enter
I don't know if I'm am I really able to
track something down maybe I am
yeah I think I might be close to winning
a pawn I think in some some lines I have
to be careful of Bishop B5
if I take here
okay that I didn't expect okay because
now it's different I could take the
queen
and now it could take on e4
Bishop here I win the full piece okay so
now
I want to get out of that
although
no let's keep the foot on the gas here
keep moving forward
F2
and this one
let's go with this one too
oh oh okay actually on this one I have
Bishop here
or no what am I talking about if the
bishop The Bishop's pinned F2
okay
and now maybe move my knight
yeah this seems like a good Square
Bishop is still pinned
where is it
hmm okay well that's a good move
it's a really good move
I'm just going to be losing something
now okay
I think I have to give up my Pawn
ah
after I recapture I'm defending this
bishop oh they missed that idea
on this night too
right here defends everything
I have the exchange I'm of the exchange
their night is under control
here I guess
watch out for passers
I feel like it should be close to May
and it takes pawn and Rook here
is a mating pattern
33 seconds Knight is still under control
back rank mates no problems maybe maybe
this is the safer
spot
okay I'm on the bishop
I got a night check Bishop's covering it
at the moment do they see that I'm on
the bishop this was also a move
okay
I guess let's just collect a pawn
check
night here is a mate
oh
okay
the King was
Super Active there
14 minutes to go
21 with fire I might be getting him I
think he just jumped up no he's in a
game against
the I am I am FM playing a game right
now
okay
somebody anybody
dragon sword
let's try C4 game or berserk I guess
we'll try oh have I got the berserk and
we'll try one berserk
so bullet
and get a bunch of exchanges in
take with this my king could step over
okay keep the diagonal open
oh
uh let's let's let's do it let's just go
for
some play on the structure
it's not allow him to go anymore oh Rook
here
[Music]
um
I think it I don't know shouldn't I win
the tempo game
with their their structure
yeah they get it's very active play
I don't know is it a one king and pawn
ending
I feel like it should be
I don't want to see that guy go any
further
put a little pressure here
I'm just allowing them to undouble
seems like like my pawns are more fluid
oh okay this should be I should be
getting the Rook Pawn now
is that really a catchable Pawn
okay we have to
I just want to circle around my queen is
defended
it'd be very difficult for them to
find a perpetual
Queen's covering everything she's golden
right here
stop that
okay
yeah you know
uh that Rook pivot on D6 was very good I
should have it I should have anticipated
that
typical idea
we'll put it on a square where if I make
the decision to initiate the capture the
pawns are straightened out
okay 11 minutes to go
uh all right how about a
King side fiend kiddo
King's Indian
question this guy maybe let's try it
like this let's go hunting for a
an imbalance
continue to follow this
path of not taking that Bishop
so soon
um
yeah let's go with this I'm not gonna
recapture I'm gonna play Queen A5 if
Pawn takes Pawn
so I'm playing it I'm playing this
position as if
I already have the imbalance
I guess there's Queen A4 in reply
didn't really take that into account
all right let me change course I guess
I'm gonna go for
um
okay let's let's do this
Queen A4 I'll exchange take on C5 Knight
takes C5 I take B2 two point pawn bishop
pair open position should be
compensation
ready to take twice here maybe I didn't
even consider that they could be
capturing like this
all right
hmm
yeah I guess you could just take like
that can you
messy
messy game
still keep the PIN
right here is going to be so strong
where am I supposed to Castle
the person in the coin exchange would
not mind that
okay I'm going here because I want to
try and tame this Knight as soon as the
pin isn't there
that's my way to tame the Knight
okay
I'll go here maybe repair the structure
I don't mind night there so much
well I guess I'm gonna go this way feels
safer there's no dark script Bishop
maybe a four is a move
yeah
I am oh I'm forgetting okay I have this
Square covered what am I doing
I want a queen Exchange
okay
anticipating that there's going to be
some pressure here
not down anything am I no even material
let's get out of that pin Queen here
no fancy Knight Forks
feels like an evenish position
queen of six
there's no way my queen is better than
theirs okay are they going for
not sure what they're going for let's go
here
I guess they're going here
I want to be able to play here okay
a check
get this in maybe a pawn here some mate
check is that anything
try this check
maybe Queen here even
I was hoping they went King H1 so that
I'm threatening a queen exchange and to
win this Pawn
not going for that oh my goodness I
missed that that was even a move
oh man
no I think my queen is just trapped
and my queen is just going to be trapped
now
oh
I don't have another Square
no I shouldn't moved that pawn I would
have had some resource here
lucky to be alive right now
oh man
this is lost
they could have just pushed there
floundering
I gotta go for time burners
ah I deserve to lose that oh man
my queen got tracked right down
oh I was lucky to even get their Queen
back like that
what was I thinking there with the queen
yeah that idea with F4
F4 G4
hmm
or actually even going back to that that
that check was just way too short-lived
that was my initial feel but I still
went with it
like she wasn't connected with anything
else
is what I'm thinking so she just turned
out to be
one piece out there trying to attack
not coordinate with anything though
okay
black already has an excellent position
in this one
easily get an E5
I wonder if I should yeah let's play
here
let's not give them a second chance to
track that guy down
may run away not
not captured now
uh let's get a little crazy
F4
let's go with this one if my Knight's
challenge I'm prepared to play F4
okay and on that move
let's try this it takes Knight he could
take the bishop with check
I don't know that this one's gonna
finish probably not
two minutes left
okay I could take here and then the king
is overloaded after the recapture
got this guy
I don't think my Queen's getting trapped
in this one
ah but that move there is very good
castles I guess
could have thrown in the check okay
why not I think about these squares
sooner
this is a poison Pawn
probably Rook h8 to get my queen out of
there
and then where do I go
Queen C2
D3 I wouldn't mind if this is in there
because then this is strengthened
let's continue on this path
Bishop's in a pin
Knight F5 Knight H5
also go here
still pinned my Knight's covering F1
I'm up the pawn
okay
now I'm gonna have to move my Rook I
guess here
I have this Square available
start with this I guess watch out for a
pawn break
restrict The Rook under a minute in the
tournament
Knight F5 has been a move for a while if
I don't want to play this too soon
because this all right
this is hitting with Tempo though
get my king on a light Square
I'm gonna try for H5
I could have also maybe tried E4 here
now but then there's a bishop check and
Rook takes Pawn all right so this could
be a move oh also this could be a move
simple doubling up
Oh I thought they might try Bishop A7
I have a good enough grip over that
okay
seems like an improvement
just a hair
threatening Knight takes Pawn
Rook is defended but not well enough
C6 Pawn is pinned A6 Pawn is pinned
well the B Pawn is pinned so these two
are up for grabs
is what I'm trying to say
let's go one
Knight's covering a lot of squares okay
let's go back here
to reroute
King on F3 feels very good
I don't like being on the same color but
I don't want to see The Rook enter
stand still here
with the B7 Pawn
I could try for this maneuver oh okay
they're down on time in the end Mr deep
blue okay
and up and up and down event not the
not the cleanest play that is for sure
where did I finish ninth
played
only nine games counted for the
tournament
okay
26 points Ninth Place first
tanza 67 52 he was cruising Jean Valjean
is in there
they're very berserky player as well 75
percent
shows it there
well let's see 475 in there
top 50.
there's your top 50.
okay fun event it's been a while since I
recorded one for the tube
good games all
right Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away that's
all for now take care bye